september is national suicide prevention
awareness month devoted to raise
awareness about suicide prevention
reduce the stigma around the topic and
encourage those in need to seek
resources and now more than ever that
includes our first
responders these agencies just like our
homes that of your public that's
watching right now they've sustained
losses from covid their families have
been affected by covid the pandemic has
changed their lives just as much as it's
changed ours all the while still having
to respond to these natural disasters
like ida
um
you know
their own day-to-day pressure of living
and the crisis of 9-1-1 calls one after
the other after the other which is the
nature of this type of work brandi lee
baker is the president and co-founder of
the code 9 project a peer support
hotline comprised of active and former
military law enforcement and first
responders dedicated to helping bring
suicide numbers down by providing
support and resources
she says the coronavirus pandemic is
putting first responders and health care
workers at a high risk for mental health
problems as they're at the front lines
providing care to others while
struggling with their own ptsd and
depression her team was recently
deployed to a department in louisiana
that experienced a department suicide
and reached out for help brandi lee
wants every agency nationwide to know
they can call her non-profit
organization day or night for help and
can find out more at thecode9project.org